[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen foreign
correspondent of the year
Murray : this is just a light touch at
Treasure Island
I need a photographer any good the best
also thinking about it once you go crazy
it's not something you get used to or is
not so terrible for governments for they
are that wounded or killed like ordinary
people our mission is to speak the truth
to power
we're prepared to thank your country in
the Civil War
what happened they've opened fire on
journalists if the government catches
you they'll kill you
I have nightmares every night you see
more war than most soldiers you have to
take it seriously
I hate being in a war zone I also feel
compelled to see it for myself because
you're addicted to it
if you use the cellphone those drones
will know where we are don't have time
no one in their right mind would do what
do you do
[Music]
he has to go back we look guy if we go
back
I want people to know your story you
have a god-given talent for making
people stop and care
- seeing alive I see it so you don't
have to take it you lose your conviction
what hope do the rest of us have maybe I
would have liked a more normal life
maybe I just don't know how
you
you